[Music]
she's probably the most exciting figure
skater on the planet
she's only 15 years old
already the story of camilla valeeva is
pretty incredible
we now know that this skating prodigy
tested positive for a banned substance
in december of last year but a delay in
the laboratories meant that the result
only came to light as beijing 2022 was
underway
[Music]
the drug itself is nicknamed tmz and is
normally used to treat heart conditions
an opinion is divided as to how helpful
it would really be to a figure skater
but it has been on the banned list since
2014.
at the last winter olympics we saw
another case of it a russian athlete in
the bobsley event who tested positive
before she was due to compete
i think we just you know feel sad for
that girl because um you know she's only
15. camilla valeeva's positive test put
the sports authorities in a difficult
position did they allow her to carry on
or take away her big olympic moments
given her age just 15 they've decided to
allow her to carry on skating while the
investigation into her positive test
continues but that means there's now
this bizarre situation where if camilla
valeeva finishes in the top three places
in her events there will be no medal
ceremonies and that is proving very
divisive clean athletes are being denied
their big moment
after a particularly bad doping scandal
in sochi in russia in 2014 russians were
punished but the ban that they faced has
still allowed russian athletes to
compete just under a different flag and
so many have called that a complete
farce and now with a 15 year old testing
positive for a banned substance the
calls for russia to be kicked out
completely are getting louder